الان عبر الهاتف من بيروت الاستاذ سركيس
ابو زيد المحلل السياسي اهلا ومرحبا بك
على فانكات تم تحديد صباح اليوم جلسه
جديده يوم الخميس المقبل جلسه اليوم باءت
يعني بالفشل كيف تفسر ذلك يعني منذ فتره
وترجيحات والاقتراحات تدور حول ترشيح كل
من همم سليمان فرنجيه
ومشيال معوض همم كما هناك معلومات يعني
تشير الامكانيه قائد الجيش لو تشرح لنا كل
هذا
يعني بدايه يعني نتائج الانتخابات
النيابيه الاخر الاخيره لم تفرز ااا
اكثريه واضحه تستطيع ان تحسم هذا الامر
لذلك لا يوجد حتى الان مرشح يستطيع ان
ينال نصف زائد واحد ايه 65 نائب من مجلس
النواب هذا حتى الان غير متوفر لذلك
الحظوظ متساويه بين جميع المرشحين
او قائد الجيش ااا
يعني
هي النتائج ستكون يعني غير حاسمه لذلك همم
مطلوب ان يكون هناك تفاهم بين الكتل
النيابيه حتى تستطيع ان تشكل اكثريه جديده
تنتخب الرئيس الجديد وهذا غير متوفر حتى
الان وذلك له سبب بين اولا يعني الاليه
الطبيعيه لانتخاب رئيس غير متوفره لحسن
هذا الموضوع كل توافق الداخلي والاطليمي
والدولي غير متوفر حتى الان للاسف بان
طبيعه الدستور اللبناني خاضع لاجتهادات
المتعدده ولا يوجد بنود تحسم هذه المسائل
الخلفيه لذلك
اخضع للدستور الى اجتهادات والى اعرف
وتقاليد بالنتيجه غير هذا لم لن يؤدي الى
النتيجه حتى الان لا يوجد تفاهم لاكثريه
جديده يعني هناك مساعي فرنسيه بالتعاون مع
مصر مع السعديه مع دول اخرى تتحاول ان
تقوم بمبادره من اجل تقريب جهات النظر من
اجل تشكيل اكثريه جديده لانتخاب رئيس ان
الظروف البلاد يعني ماساويه والوطن
اقتصادي المالي متراجع لذلك مطلوب ان يكون
هناك رئيس جمهوريه لحتى يكون هناك احد
ادنى من من الاستقرار ولكن للاسف هذا
الامور غير موجوده هل ستنجح همم فرنسا في
عقد الطويل الى مستدير لك مفاوضات ان كان
بفرنسا او بالمصر او في لبنان او غيرها
هذا الموضوع لم يحسم بعد ولكن هناك مساعده
جديه باختصار ما اريد ان اقوله لن يكون
للبنان رئيس بغض النظر عن الجلسات ستكون
هذه الجلسات مسرحيه تتكرر كل اسبوع ولكنها
لم تؤدي الى نتيجه قبل ان يكون هناك توافق
اما داخلي او اقليمي دولي يساعد على توفير
اكثر يتستطيع ان ان تنتخب رئيس وللاسف بان
هذا الوضع يفتح البلاد امام احتمالات
خطيره لان هذا الوضع يزيد من الماسات
الاقتصاديه الاجتماعيه مما يؤدي ربما يؤدي
الى الى تصاعد عمليات العنف او او او
الحركه الاجتماعيه ربما تزداد او عوده الى
الحراك في الشارع او ربما احد يستغل هذه
الامور يعني من اجل احداث امنيه تؤدي الى
ربما يعني حرب اهليه متنقله او احداث
امنيه متنقله تزيد من خراب البلد من ذلك
مطلوب ان يكون هناك عقلاء في الطبقه
السياسيه اللبنانيه من اجل التوصل الى حل
سياسي ولو مرحل اوانه والا ستدخل البلاد
بحاله من الفوضى والخراف لا احد يستطيع عن
الخطر
اشكرك يا استاذه المحلل سي كنت معنا
مباشره من بيروت